this page is from alan turing's school
report card
his math teacher says that his work
shows distinct promise
but he must realize that the ability to
put a neat and tidy solution on paper
is necessary for a first-rate
mathematician
and his physics teacher says that in
order to get into cambridge
he will need to show sound knowledge
rather than
vague ideas now with these
vague ideas turing would go on to
crack the enigma encryption that germany
used during world war
ii and helped to end the war that was
featured in the movie all about
touring called the imitation game turing
was
an incredibly talented mathematician and
also one of the first
computer scientists he envisioned
computers as the tool
for which we use them today and he gave
one of the first lectures to mention the
idea of
computer intelligence the idea from
which the field of artificial
intelligence would grow
so hello i'm toby and welcome back
to another video where i'm going to be
going through someone's grades
also a thank you to the great courses
plus for
sponsoring part of this video this page
of turing's report card
was from 1929 when tearing was about 17
years old
and attending the sherborne school in
england
his french was considered fair and his
proses were weak
and his reading was apparently weak as
well his essays showed ideas that were
more grandiose than pointed
it is a common thread throughout
tearing's report cards that he did much
better in maths and science
than he did in the languages a tutor
remarks at the end of this page that
they are
satisfied and glad that turing is ready
to come out of his shell
that's not too bad but many of the
earlier report cards for touring
were much more harsh this particular
page was the only original photocopy i
could find
but i do have a transcribed version of
all of the other years that tyrion was
at this school
and some of these comments are really
tough you can read through all of the
comments in this document yourself
this is on the sherbourne school website
but i'll read through some of the
comments that really stood out to me
turing's first year at the school was in
1926
when he was aged 14 and it was said that
he had a natural bent for science but
his work was badly spoiled by extreme
untidiness now this mention of untidy or
dirty work
would become a very common thread
through a lot of these comments
his teachers used words like careless
and disappointing
and they even called his lack of
interest in french
very depressing these pages are full of
comments
saying things like his work is rather
lacking in life
or that he needs to concentrate harder
or even this note
saying that he is not a normal boy
in mathematics he ranked 10th in his
class and the comment says
not very good he spends a good deal of
time apparently in
investigations of advanced mathematics
to the neglect of his elementary work
a sound groundwork is essential in any
subject
his work is dirty i guess i agree with
the sentiment that you need to have
some good foundations before you go on
into advanced stuff
but man that comment seems really
demoralizing for a kid who is obviously
very interested in the subject turing
was indeed interested
in these investigations of advanced
mathematics
when he was aged 15 and a half he wrote
a condensed version of
einstein's general theory of relativity
as
a gift to his mother and i'll put some
pictures up of that document on the
screen for you to have a look at
i think that it's really impressive for
someone of his age to be reading
and clearly thinking about some of the
subjects and topics in that book
so i think you can clearly see he was a
talented kid
who cared for mathematics but like many
students i think
he struggled to bring this talent and
enthusiasm for science
with him through the conventional
education system
and some of these comments from his
professors
are kind of trying to do their best to
really beat that passion out of him
his history teacher says i append one
sheet of a recent history paper as it
probably stays more eloquently than i
can
where his weakness lies this homework
was
an essay that turing wrote and i guess
it's a little messy at the start
but by today's standards his handwriting
is pretty nice so
yeah i'm not really sure maybe we'd have
to have a little read of that essay to
truly understand
he's been at the school for a little
while now but is still getting told that
he's too
untidy and that there's room for
improvement
in science the comment is that he has
a lot of knowledge but his methods and
practical work
are at present deplorable he must
learn the importance of scrupulous
cleanliness and neatness
and of being able to set his work down
on paper
now it seems kind of surprising to read
these sorts of comments about
turing as an experimentalist because
i mean even if you've seen the movie the
imitation game
the machines that he dreamt up and
worked on
were you know very neat made of many
moving parts
and required a brain that could see how
everything
fit together very neatly and you know in
a very beautiful way for the mathematics
to work so
i don't know if turing improved or
if you know his his talents just weren't
able to
shine while he was at school there's
kind of a funny comment down here on the
house report
saying that no doubt he is very
aggravating
and he should know by now that i don't
care to find him
boiling heaven knows what witches brew
by the aid of two guttering candles on a
naked wooden window
sill i think this is referring to turing
performing
one of many experiments outside of class
you see this was a boarding school
and turing loved to have his own little
experiments
not sure what he was concocting here but
yeah it sounds maybe like it was even a
chemistry experiment
by 1928 there were still plenty of
struggles
turing ranked third in his class for
mathematics
although the comment says that he was
easily the best mathematician in the set
so really he deserved to come first his
position
is caused again by untidiness and
carelessness his english teacher says
that
he should read more and that's
interesting because
there are also the library records of
touring available on the school's
website
and you can see that whilst he got out a
lot of books
on things like math and science he only
ever
got out three fiction books and two of
those were
part of the alice in wonderland series
by lewis carroll
and the reason he got out those books
was because one of his math teachers had
encouraged him to
since the author of alice in wonderland
lewis carroll was himself a
mathematician
and there was a lot of math sprinkled
into those stories
there are sentences like this one from
the headmaster
saying that he better take on the advice
of his teachers
if he is to achieve any real success
and that kind of hurts to read because
you know
turing's work did go on to be so
influential to mathematics and
he definitely by any standard did
achieve
real success in his field by 1930 though
things started to look a little bit more
positive
his physics teacher this time said that
he is doing much better work
the headmaster says that he seems to be
going well
and the house report says that he wins
respect
both by brains and character the
comments and pretty much every subject
including the languages
are much more positive you know we have
steady and intelligent work from the
english teacher
which is you know such a step up from
those very harsh comments at the start
they commend him for working hard and
having imagination and
interest even in his language subjects
this is the final page and the final
comments
are that he is considered pleasant and
friendly
and the headmaster has appointed him a
school prefect
they wish him success at cambridge
university
for which he had gained a scholarship
i'm happy that by the end you know all
these teachers who had been so harsh
did wish him well and and commend him
for his intelligence and his hard work
i don't know how much of that is touring
you know
becoming more mature maybe he did decide
that he did
you know need to be a lot neater to um
to really get his ideas across
and after cambridge he eventually went
on to get a phd in number theory from
princeton university
as a fun little bonus here are some
pictures of
a number theory book that turing owned
and annotated
and this book was written by john
littlewood
who you may remember from my previous
videos about the romanogen
and hardy sort of collaboration because
littlewood was also involved in that
story too
so a little bit of you know crossing
over between these two stories
another little fun fact is that alan
turing's middle name was
matheson and i kind of find that fitting
seeing as it sounds like the sun of math
although what would be more fitting
would to call tearing the
father of computer science now we can't
end on that happy note though because
tearing's life
did have a really tragic end
in 1952 he was arrested
when being gay was considered a criminal
offence
he chose to be chemically castrated
instead of going to prison
and he died two years later at the age
of 42.
he took a bite of an apple which he had
laced with cyanide
perhaps a result of the depressing
circumstances in which he found himself
in 2009 the british government issued an
apology
for the treatment of alan turing but it
remains
a really sad story and a tragic end
for one of our greatest minds and it
remains an example
of how hatred and discrimination can
rob the world of wonderful people
this part of the video is sponsored by
the great courses plus
much of alan turing's work was
philosophical in nature
he devised a test that could evaluate a
machine's ability
to exhibit intelligence he wondered
is there anything about us that is
different
from a properly programmed machine
today we call this the turing test
and i have explored ideas like this with
the help of a course from the great
courses plus
called the great ideas of philosophy
the lectures are presented by daniel
robinson
who had been a member of the oxford
university's philosophy faculty
and there is a lecture about alan turing
in the forest of wisdom
the great courses plus is a subscription
learning service
with content from top universities and
places like
national geographic and the smithsonian
they're offering a free trial so head to
thegreatcoursesplus.com slash tippies
and see what you can learn they have
over 11 000 video lectures
on topics including science math
philosophy and literature so thanks to
the great courses plus
for providing this resource and for
supporting my channel
head to the link in the description
below to start your free trial today
thanks for watching the video and thanks
as always to my patreon supporters
including today's patreon cat of the day
tilly
[Music]